everywhere they know who my father is
and they've been touched in some way
inspired in some way or just excited in
some way and it's such a blessing I now
work doing things for the legacy for
through my foundation and through our
licensing business and that sort of
thing but I'm just so amazed and so
inspired on a daily basis and it's
really why I want to do what I do in
keeping the legacy alive because I'm
inspired by it if you know there hadn't
been that depth of philosophy behind it
if there hadn't been so much more to it
and so much authenticity to it then I
don't know that I'd be doing what I'm
doing today I had been doing things like
judo and Japanese karate and stuff like
that and eventually I began to seeing
other other kinds of things Bruce
obviously helped me a good bit and I
would ask him what do you what do you
think I try to do this kind of thing he
said that's pretty good tried that and
we were working like that all the time
I probably didn't mean it but it
well I when I got the to to Hong Kong I
was there with my wife and my son was
not yet two years old and the next day I
went to see Bruce and he brought me into
his house he was waiting to see me and
um and then I saw he had a gem and and I
looked at it and reminded me what I had
a little bit of at my home you know
and we began to talk this and that may
be so many things what he could do with
kettlebells and stuff and things that I
had little can't contact with at that
time and we kept going on and on and on
and then all of a sudden he began to
tell me um show me show me how you do
your psychic and I said okay but I had
done a scene at the park about Oh two
three weeks or four weeks prior where I
had sprained my ankle and I said oh well
all right he's wanting to do this with
me well do it you know so um all of a
sudden uh I threw a kick and then he
said let me show how I do mine and he
did he he moved around with a chair and
I didn't know what he was doing you know
I was looking over my shoulder like that
and all of a sudden he stood in front of
day for about 15 feet or something like
that and he did a hop skip and a jump
and he I had a bag you know and he
knocked me clear across on my heels like
this going into a chair like that and
the chair fell down and broke and I got
up Lin and I saw he was very kind of
quiet and and anxious about this and I
said listen uh it's okay I mean no I
didn't get hurt I didn't get hurt he
says I know but that's my best chair
and it was the same chair that he had
everybody else do the same thing with me
that I discovered later sit behind the
stand behind it and then he'd kick and
you'd go back and boom you hit this
chair but I have broken it I was the
only one that had broken it okay I love
Bruce Lee and we were really close
friends for many many many years over
ten and training partners and and I got
five hundred a week when I was making
ten to twelve thousand a week my real
estate business
my wife of 44 years now said why are you
doing this I just love Bruce he's my
first close Chinese friend and I can
take these hits and everybody's afraid
of them and I've been training with him
I can take the hits and and Bruce want
to do everything real he really Freddie
and Paul can tell you they Bruce got
hurt a lot in this film he got bit by
the snake he got hurt by the windows he
got cut with a glass scene with me we're
using real bottles so my part in it was
I was really enjoying it you don't see
yourself as a bad guy all of my life
does he thought it was typecasting and
I've had so many people over the years
say I hated you I wanted you get even
Freddy said I wanted I wanted him to
kill you and he'd even want to hire me
for the part in the beginning but but I
really enjoyed doing it I loved Bruce
and it was it's like my partner for four
years is Chuck Norris and they're both
the same Chuck and Bruce and people say
you've never missed a workout with
either one of them and I said no why
would you miss a painting lesson from
Picasso